une semaine après la levée des codes qr
à moscou le secteur de la restauration
reprend son activité estivale malgré les
craintes des détracteurs de la décision
de la mairie de supprimer les
certificats numériques
la courbe des contaminations continue de
baisser selon le maire de moscou sergueï
sobianine
la situation s'est améliorée et les
moscovites peuvent souffler cette seule
semaine
le nombre de cas a baissé de 27% et la
baisse a été forte auparavant de deux
fois et plus on a surmonté le pic de la
crise j'espère qu'une situation plus ou
moins stable va désormais se mettre en
place
l'autre question est de savoir pour
combien de temps on va voir pour le
moment on peut souffler un peu les
restaurateurs se réjouissent du retour
de la clientèle est celle ci affluent
sur les terrasses avec la mise en place
des codes qr nous avons vu refus non
seulement de moscovites mais aussi des
touristes dans la capitale
pour eux il était assez difficile
d'obtenir des codes qr et de s'assurer
qu'il soit en ordre lors de leur entrée
dans un restaurant l'activité est revenu
très vite ce que nous observons pour
l'instant c'est que toutes les
modifications mises en place sont de
court terme et que les entreprises et
les citoyens se sont habitués à de tels
changements et s'y adapte très vite le
rétablissement des flux a eu lieu en
quelques jours
de manière générale j'étais pour les
codes qr parce qu'il faut faire
comprendre aux gens que ce n'est pas
simplement le virus il faut lutter
contre et ne pas négliger la vaccination
il me semble que nous avons eues les
codes qr pendant trop peu de temps il
aurait fallu patienter encore deux mois
j'aime beaucoup ça on peut à nouveau
aller partout nous prenons nos
précautions bien sûr nous venons d'aller
au restaurant et étions en terrasse
j'aime le sentiment de liberté qu'il n'y
ait pas d'interdiction il est évident
qu'il faut lutter contre le virus et que
nous ne pourrons pas nous en débarrasser
complètement
il faut s'habituer à vivre avec lui pour
le moment c'est difficile
comment faire n'est pas clair c'est plus
pratique mais le vaccin c'est important
parce que la sécurité c'est important je
suis d'accord peut-être que la levée des
qr codes ne contribue pas à
l'amélioration de la situation sanitaire
mais au moins pour nous en tant que
client de café c'est plus pratique
les restrictions n'ont pas complètement
disparu de la vie des moscovites
les codes qr sont demandés d'un certain
musées et théâtres et en cas de hausse
des contaminations les certificats
numériques risque de revenir